-Oh, everybody's saying it.
Congratulations.
I'm so happy for you.
Best movie of the year.
Okay, I'll stop.
Let's get down to business.
-It's well-deserved.
It is a great movie and I'm glad
everybody's bringing it up
because, you know,
Questlove kind of got cheated
out of some attention there
at the Oscars.
-I know.
It's like I thought that was
going to be, you know --
Well, it was a pretty memorable
moment, for a lot of reasons.
-It was, indeed.
-But I'm so happy for you.
And it's so great to meet you.
-And we are happy for you
and I think I speak
for Questlove when I say that
because your show is,
first of all, just picked up
for a second season.
-That's correct.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughs ]
-A really great show.
-Thank you.
-Funny and moving
and all of those things
you would want from a show.
And the show is set,
for those who don't know,
in your actual hometown,
Manhattan, Kansas.
Did you shoot it
in your hometown?
-Well, we shot
a little bit there.
We shot some outside of Chicago,
but it's Manhattan, Kansas,
the Little Apple.
If you haven't been,
you got to go.
Stop by Varsity Donuts.
It's a really good time.
-Did they just call it
the Little Apple
or is there
some representation of --
-Oh, it's called that.
There's like, you know,
like a big water tower
with an apple on it
and there's like
Little Apple Brewery,
Little Apple this,
Little apple that, so.
-And what college is
in Manhattan, Kansas?
-Kansas State. Powercats.
-But you did not go
to Kansas State.
-No, I went to Arizona State.
-And I went
to Arizona State, too.
-That's what I heard.
-Yeah.
I don't know
if we overlapped at all.
I didn't actually go to class,
so that was --
[ Laughter ]
-I barely did,
but I studied opera.
Were you...?
-Same here.
[ Laughter ]
-What were you up to
when you were there?
What were you doing
like socially?
-Oh, God. Just, you know.
-Where'd you hang out?
-The Dash.
-The Dash was the big
place then, yeah.
-Yeah. And then Whataburger
on the way home
and that was pretty much it.
[ Laughter ]
-I learned a special skill
at The Dash,
which was that you don't need
a glass to drink beer out of.
You can just drink it
right out of the pitcher.
-That's right. That's right.
And, as a matter of fact,
I used to be on the swim team --
for like one year --
but you would drink
a whole pitcher of beer
and then your alarm would go off
at like 5:00 in the morning
and you'd throw up
in the gutter, so, anyway.
[ Laughter ]
It was a different time.
Now, I just, you know,
throw up anywhere.
[ Laughter ]
It's New York.
-You brought a video for us
of your mother.
-Oh, yeah.
-Who's an interesting woman.
-Yeah.
-I think maybe we should show
the video first.
-Let's get to know her
a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, sure.
-Teeny tiny penis.
-[ Laughs ]
-What was the teeny tiny penis?
-He had a little [bleep]
-Who?
-Your father.
[ Laughter ]
But he used it plenty,
believe me.
-With who?
-With anybody
he could get it in.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-Dear old dad.
So your mom is not the shy
and reserved type,
is what I'm guessing.
-Oh,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We used to go to Food 4 Less,
which was
a grocery store at the time.
-Yeah. It still is.
-Yeah.
-Kind of.
-She would go in like
her nightgown,
but like just paper thin.
It'd be like from the '70s
and we're in the late '80s
by now.
And she said these long,
long hanging boobs.
We called it beaver tails.
And she would just walk.
[ Laughter ]
You know, just didn't give a --
She did not care.
But I think, you know,
in some ways,
that's kind of what brought me
to this moment right now.
-Oh, inspiration, yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh, I'm getting hot, Jimmy.
I'm getting hot.
[ Laughter ]
No, I mean, if you see these
without this --
Somebody make a good
plus-size bra
because, if I took
this thing off,
they'd be rolling
around my knees and...
I'd be like mother,
like daughter right now.
[ Laughter ]
Cut this.
Fix this in post.
Cut this whole interview.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hi, guys.
[ Laughter ]
Did you stay in Phoenix
after college
or did you go back home?
-I did, I stayed in Arizona
for a while.
I was knocking around
in karaoke bars
and I was waiting tables
at P.F. Chang's,
the original one,
thank you so much.
-Oh, the original, yeah, yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-The original one.
In Scottsdale Fashion Square.
It was a real hot spot
for like sports celebrities.
-Oh, really?
Like who?
-Oh, you got your, oh, you know,
your Charles Barkley, of course.
-Oh, he played for the Suns.
-And he was huge at the time
and he brought in everybody.
Like one night,
I was waiting on him
and Michael Jordan
and Payne Stewart
and Ahmad Rashad
and all these people.
But one night, he brought in
"The Nature Boy" Ric Flair.
[ Laughs ]
-The wrestler.
The great wrestler, yeah.
-Whoo! Anybody -- Okay.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Anyway.
-Some of them are still
holding back tears.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Well, I'm happy you're here.
Anyway, The Nature Boy,
I was so excited because like
I grew up with him
in the household.
He was like, you know,
my brothers used
to watch wrestling
and like body slam me and stuff.
It was wonderful.
[ Laughter ]
-He had that beautiful mane
of blond hair.
-Yeah, showbiz, you know.
Total wrestler,
like with the outfits.
You got to look him up.
If you don't know
The Nature Boy Ric Flair,
you got to look him up.
Anyway, I'm sort of going off.
-What did Nature Boy like
to eat?
-Well, Nature Boy,
I don't know what he got up to,
but I do know Charles Barkley
was my regular,
so he had the pot stickers.
He got those.
-Oh, Charles liked
the pot stickers.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Was Charles a good tipper?
-Charles was a very consistent,
good tipper.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah, and there was
a whole range
with some of those sports stars,
but, yeah,
he was always a good tipper.
-Ooh! Oh, so some of them
stiffed you, huh?
-No, no, no, no, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
But he was good.
He would have me sing sometimes.
Because, if you didn't know,
I'm a singer.
You can look it up on YouTube.
It's everywhere.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, so, you knew him
really well.
-Well, enough, you know.
It was kind of like he was --
Let me just have
a little sip of water.
-Yeah, go ahead.
Enjoy. Go crazy.
-You got to stay hydrated.
It's flu season.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, my point was that
he brought in
Nature Boy Ric Flair
and I was so freaked out
because like, to me,
like he was like, that was like
a movie star, you know,
in the flash and he's like,
"Do you want to sing for him?"
I was like, "I don't know,"
and then so I just --
He's like, "Come on,
sing for him," but I was scared,
so I sat
on Charles Barkley's lap
[ Laughter ]
and sang and sort of
with my head
like sort of buried in his neck
and I sang
"I've Got a Crush on You"
to The Nature Boy Ric Flair,
[ Laughter and applause ]
just one chair over.
And I doubt either one of them
remember that,
but it was one of the best
moments of my life.
-It's a pretty good life moment.
-Yeah.
-Well, it's great to have
you here.
-Thank you.
-The show, if you haven't
seen it, it's great.
It's called
"Somebody Somewhere."
It's on HBO and HBO Max.
Bridget Everett, everybody.
Thank you, Bridget.